if you're afraid of coming down and
going swimming in the ocean because of
sharks you should be terrified to make a
piece of toast 400 people died last year
from defective toasters whereas less
than 10 did from sharks this is the
first large shark expedition like this
in the western Gulf will be tagged in
hammerhead sharks tiger sharks and mako
sharks trying to understand how they're
leveraging the Gulf in their berthing
mating and full migratory patterns will
be getting up every day just before dawn
the fishing team will be going out
getting all of our lines rigged and
ready to go and then we'll get the ship
in position with a lift in the water and
we'll be looking to capture bring sharks
back to the lift lift them up out of the
water and once we do that a whole team
of scientists from a half dozen
institutions will circle around the
shark and will conduct 12 research
projects in about 15 minutes then
release the shark and open source the
tracking to the world so that everyone
can follow it
what we're finding is that these massive
sharks have huge huge movements across
the ocean we have one of these white
sharks Lydia who's traveled over 35,000
miles in just two years very very
regular for these sharks to be swimming
a thousand miles a month which is why
it's so important to figure out where
they go
we're losing 200,000 sharks a day for
shark fin soup a hundred million a year
you know people need to understand an
ocean with no sharks means an ocean with
no fish they are the lion the balance
keeper of the ocean and if they are not
there the whole food chain collapses
this is a simple battle we got to solve
the puzzle of these sharks lives to make
sure they flourish and make a difference
for the future
you